so leute kann man das schon raus so
richtig geil was wir zu sagen wieviele
likes für diese pizza aus was willst du
sagen 10.000 10.000 war möglich so gut
super klasse gedacht netz willkommen
zwei einem neuen video ja leute ich bin
hier gerade mit platzieren
es geht würde man auf jeden fall geht
christian bald nach england und jetzt
zeigt mir wenn youtube kanal ist also
dass gerade der coole idee kommt für ein
video weil wir haben hunger und
christian wollte mir grad mal seinen
youtube channel zeigen ich zeige euch
mal kurz sich ein kanalrohr da ist auf
jeden fall also dass folgen auf jeden
fall jede menge coole videos ich
verlinke euch das mal ganz oben in der
video beschreiben das muss man
abonnieren so und wir haben heute ich
hab ja nicht was zuerst mitgemacht
wir haben nur das ding ist das ist ein
bisschen wenig deswegen müssen jetzt
auch im herzen köpfen machen und da das
video nicht einfach darin bestehen soll
dass wir als essen machen wir was
krasses und zwar testen wir
tiefkühlprodukte wo es ist fast food
produkte also von einer fast food kette
ich will jetzt gar nicht den namen
nennen oder so also haben wir pizza
chicken nuggets und dann kommt gleich
noch burger dazu wenn wir was cooles
finden und das wird dann so ein bisschen
getestet und mal gucken was besser
schmeckt weil ich glaube diese dinge wie
zum beispiel die mega ich will meine
guten ideen was sagst du dazu
das noch nicht so lecker aus aber ich
lasse mich überraschen würde ich sagen
wie lange schlange fahren los
ich fühle mich jetzt leute wir waren
jetzt gerade einkaufen für einmal kurz
wir haben es noch so einen schönen
bürger und chicken nuggets
ja und jetzt geht es zu einer fast food
filiale unseres vertrauens und da wird
der rest kommt dann braucht er noch eine
pizza von einem schönen andere fastfood
restaurant aber die müssen wir halt auch
noch kaufen also wir machen hier eine
halbe weltreise nur um ein video zu
drehen tiefkühlprodukte us fastfood
produkte
ich bin gespannt ja das ist jetzt wieder
zu viele glauben so leute waren es
gerade unterwegs und haben bisschen
einkauft ist ja echt mega anstrengend
ich war noch keine stunde hat tricks um
alles zu bekommen mittlerweile haben wir
auch einfach schon krass
ich war um halb zwei hier jetzt haben
wir den alltag auf jeden fall waren wir
jetzt fast zwei stunden unterwegs und
wir haben jetzt hier einmal also dass
wir sind einmal die fertigen produkte
das ding ist die sind jetzt schon fertig
und die werden kalt deswegen müssen wir
sind mega beeilen und hier haben wir
einmal
und hier haben wir einmal ich bin so
gespannt ich habe noch nie so einen
parkplätzen so sieht eben nicht so
lecker aus tiefkühlpizza chicken nuggets
und nochmal chicken nuggets also ich
glaube sie sind klar besser gesagt habe
hier sogar saucen dabei sind 60 aus 2
auf augenhöhe mcdonald's unterschriften
schon sagen wir machen uns jetzt mal
warm und dann wird gegessen und ich bin
gespannt natürlich weiß man ja auch wie
so was ungefähr schmeckt aber dann so im
direkten vergleich keine ahnung
das ganze ist jetzt schon mal drin fragt
ob sie haben wir auch gefunden und den
bürger da kommt jetzt gleich einmal da
ist ja eigentlich schon fast fertig hast
du sonst möglicherweise tragen zum
anbeißen vergleichbar sind wenigstens
sind wenigstens hier so zu sagen können
und auch da nicht so leute werden jetzt
den wagen auch rein getan
er ist wahrscheinlich mehr gestalt
fertig aber ja ich habe heute wirklich
noch nichts gegessen
heute kann man das schon raus so richtig
geil ist so eine mischung aus allem was
da drin ist so leute christian jetzt
auch wir holen das jetzt raus also die
plätze
auf jeden fall jetzt gut fertig brachte
herr jung was das denn wo sollen wir
denn nur benutzt ja das ist welche von
den beiden sieht besser aus die wir ganz
klar oder
dann wäre auch zwei unterschiedliche das
nie von aha aber immer der bürger sieht
jetzt aber ganz ok aus oder sondern
jetzt haben wir hier einmal das fast
food essen 11 fall cool hier warst du
dabei bist du mich mal gut also das ist
schon was euch anfang mussten wir uns
wieder so ich würde sagen in der mine
müsste ich fange mit den langsam die
sind echt und diese hier sind noch
lauwarm und jahres heißt also dass jetzt
die tiefgekühlten ehrlich laufe gut und
dem verletzten noch mal so gut erwartet
also an sich war ganz gut jetzt kommen
die anderen hier nicht so also ich muss
sagen die schmecken so ein bisschen
künstlich
wenn man das jetzt sofort miteinander
probiert sagt also wenn jetzt einer 64
von ihnen denken oder sechs hier fahren
ich bin dann diese sechs weiter essen so
christian du wirst jetzt sagen fangen
wir mit den kinderschuhen
was jetzt dazu werden wir nochmal
consumer kannst doch mal den korrigieren
das ist die original ja die sind von
fast food restaurant erfordert das mit
original zu tun also im vergleich zu den
vielleicht die gar nicht probier mal
recht gut da ich mir natürlich auch
nicht frisch zubereiteten ein bisschen
frisch zubereitet also wenn man alle
sind halte die sind ja an sich auch
frisch zubereitet nur halt vom hass wut
laden zwecken nicht
also meldet schon schmecken aber nicht
so gut aber im vergleich zu dem hier und
sie sagen was er sagen soll kann ich war
nicht lustig dass der pizza weitermachen
ok dann machen wir christian zu lieben
mit der pz
hmm ich mir richtig gut alles also das
ist die erste pizza vom fast leistung
unseres vertrauens man das gerade von
110 was wir zu sagen was willst du sagen
wie viele leicht für diese pizza aus was
willst du sagen 10.000 10.000 war
ich möchte so gut superklasse ok jetzt
schneidet man irgendwie noch gar nicht
beschnitten
ok jetzt kommen die tiefkühlpizza was
willst du erst in der nacht nach ja ich
kann dir eine die andere ist es besser
nichts zu sagen okay es mir nicht um das
heißt wir haben mehr sein eins zu eins
also einmal für tiefkühl einmal für
fragen ja klar aber bei dem anderen
waren wir einer meinung
vielleicht gehört irgendwie schön luftig
hälfte nicht gut ja klar gut schon aber
also muss man ganz klar sagen musst hier
ist auf jeden fall derzeit besser aber
ich find here ist irgendwie so der belag
besser weiß was ich meine
button muss einfach noch kurz hier
reinbeißen hallo die war viel besser das
hier würde ich sagen ist eine art ich
würde sagen gleich sein und das auch
noch
ich muss jetzt erstmal auf 14 punkte und
kommen wir zur finalen runde zusätzlich
ein bisschen vorbereitet wir haben
einmal hier die fastfood burger und hier
den selbstgemachten tiefkühler okay
eigentlich ist er nicht selbst gemacht
so das ist jetzt der das ist er
münchen sid jetzt mit dem käse irgendwie
scheiße aus
also ich bin das sieht aber besser aus
als nicht im rufen also als vorher sagt
nachricht nicht weismachen okay ja geht
das ich möchte sogar das ist natürlich
nicht so gut was wir zu sagen die leute
wie viele live season bürger dann nicht
nicht gut ist
drei von zehn also lasst mich mal
deutschland probiere ich dann auch mal
sofort eben ich weiß mal hier rein wo
für käse ist ja dass man denkt erste das
geht aber nicht mit im nachhinein so und
ich finde das schmeckt regel gar nicht
sagt berger sowie das schmeckt mir diese
toilette die schlagmänner kartoffel
kartoffel ja so nach kartoffeln also
erkennst du diese reise buchen so aus
kartoffeln so schlägt das du sofort als
vergleich hier gestern
ich glaube es liegt auch daran dass man
schon so weit dass dann erwartet wenn
man so einen normalen stadion ist also
das ist ja alles klar
breit wie du schon gesagt habe und das
hier ist dann halt eben acht spiele habe
ich einige von euch wissen richtiger
bürgerkrieg und ich habe schon so gerne
bürger überall auf der welt gegessen ich
war schon in amerika hier war dann aber
ziemlich viele und lies man halt ein
besseres gewohnt sowie christian muss
jetzt ganz kurzen hier probieren
ich kann nicht zu haben ich schaffe das
wir lassen das hier nicht so legen wir
haben es jetzt wohl und das wieder
aufgehalten weil das nicht die sonne
erklärte punkte was wird zu sagen okay
deutsche jaxx gehört so viele erstmal zu
dem thema das heißt was hat gewonnen
ganz klar haben die fast food produkte
gewonnen
mit 2 zu 1 also nur die tiefgekühlten
chicken nuggets kann ich euch an filme
können wir euch empfehlen
dass nämlich die also das war nicht die
jetzt noch nicht die war nämlich nicht
auf sich warten weil lieber also achtet
darauf dass die auch wirklich schön
aussehen und schmecken hier also chicken
nuggets jahr fest nein so ist hast du
noch mal kurz zeit werbung für deinen
kanal zu machen
abonniert auf jeden fall christian den
kanal was wird also folgen und jetzt mal
kurz ich bin selbst ein bisschen herum
experimentieren was genau ich da so hoch
laden werde ja wahrscheinlich dann eher
mal ein blog oder so heißt das land wie
reisen werde und generell hoffe ich dass
ich ein ganz unterhaltsames leben dafür
wäre und wenn ihr bock hat einfach
vorbei schaut vorbei autofenster oder
sogar ein paar sachen hoch und ja also
dann wünschte ganz viel glück
das war's mit dem video wir sehen uns
wieder morgen wieder haut rein